twitch recently broke its silence on all
things
hot tubs pools and beaches by pushing
them into a category where advertisers
can pretend
they don't exist speaking of advertisers
twitch
also recently pulled streamer amaranth
amaranth's ability
to run ads on her channel before turning
around and stating
nah we're just kidding and reversing its
decision
this situation is confusing and honestly
extremely twitch so let's break down the
changes
and where water on the platform goes
from here
now listen i'd like to say that if you
hit the like button
and subscribe to the channel that i
would do this video from a hot tub
but i don't want to lie to you i
wouldn't do that regardless you should
do all of those things anyway
and also hit that notification bell so
you never miss new content ever again
plus if you want to leave a comment
about what my hands should or shouldn't
be doing
go ahead and do that as well so on may
18th amaranth announced on twitter that
twitch had
seemingly without warning pulled her
ability to advertise on her channel
which sounds as bad as it seems as being
able to run ads on your channel
is a huge source of cash money for
streamers
how huge are we talking well in the case
of amaranth she replied to a reddit
thread stating that it was going to cost
her
between 35 and 40 000
a month which for all you math heads out
there
is roughly between 420 and 480
thousand dollars a year now i
interviewed amaranth and not only did
she confirm that number
but here's what she had to say about
twitch initially
pulling ads on her channel i noticed
that for like a week i wasn't getting ad
money and i've had that
issue in the past but it was like a
glitch where it wouldn't show your
revenue and then it would be fixed a few
days later
that's when i reached out to my account
manager and was like hey i think
something's up with my account i don't
see any ad revenue even though i've been
running ads
and she checked two and she's like yeah
you have been i'll take a look so she
didn't have any idea
i don't know i'm not twitch i can't say
if that's valid or not but
it is weird that then suddenly be like
never mind and reverse it
a few days later from there she talked
about how this set an alarming precedent
and served as a warning that it doesn't
matter if you fall within terms of
service
or community guidelines twitch will
still demonetize you
if they really want to a few days later
twitch announced in a lengthy blog post
that it would be creating a new category
for hot tubs and hot tub adjacent
streams
aptly called hot tubs pools and beaches
we'll talk in detail about this latest
blog post and what it means in just a
bit
twitch then reversed its decision to
pull amaranth's ability to run
ads because of course they did the
platform has a long history of making
impulsive decisions
before clarifying them or walking them
back here's amaranth on twitch reversing
its decision
yeah they had a call with me the day
they were releasing the category like
like a few minutes before they made the
announcement i had a
call with my partner manager and the
head of partnerships and they like
explained like the ad
situation explained but still also vague
they didn't actually have a date for me
when they would come back either but
apparently people saw ads that day on my
channel so
the initial decision by twitch to pull
ads
is honestly unprecedented and comes
after
months of people complaining that women
sitting
in vessels containing water while
wearing bathing suits
was somehow ruining the platform we
covered the hot tub meta and the
beginning of this controversy on this
show
when it started happening her bands and
the rise of this hot tub meta
has reignited debates not only about
twitch's terms of service
but how to best understand the insane
rules
on this platform as this trend began to
dominate the conversation on twitch
the conversation loosely split into two
pools
tubs buckets sinks you get the point
generally speaking you had the people
who thought twitch was sliding down
into the realm of softcore porn only fan
style
content and that hot tub streams were
ruining the
platform and were bad for business
within that group there were people like
qt cinderella who
while fully supporting women making
their money thought that the sexually
suggestive content at the heart of hot
tub streams
belonged on a different platform this
opinion
is easy to understand a large portion of
twitch's user base
are young impressionable kids who
probably shouldn't be bombarded with
this type of content
add in the sensitive sensibilities of
advertisers who
probably don't want their product tied
to content that could be construed as
inappropriate
and it's understandable how a hot tub
stream could freak out some
corporate schmuck this is something that
amaranth talked about in our interview
before they had pulled my ads i had
predicted like i don't think for
a viewer experience it really matters
because if you don't like it don't watch
it you can pretend it doesn't exist
but from a an advertiser standpoint i
could see how it could
be conflicting with them wanting to
advertise on twitch if they see all
these
thumbnails of girls and bikinis and then
lo and behold that happened to me and me
alone so i should have just been silent
in the other pool sync bucket or tub
you had people like youtuber valkyrie
who didn't understand why everyone was
so mad
or what the problem was this group was
essentially saying hey
nobody's forcing you to watch this if
you don't like this
content simple just don't click on it
easy early on xqc was in this pool and
defended streamer's ability to make
money any way that they could
but then he pulled a 180 and tweeted out
about how hot tub streams were ruining
everything which honestly is an
extremely xqc thing to do
this whole where do you land on hot tubs
conversation got
so pervasive it even roped in valorant
dads
like hiko it's easy you just don't watch
if you don't like the content don't
watch
i feel like twitch is the only place
where people people are vocal about the
things they don't like to watch
and an important sentiment in the what's
the problem
pool were the people calling out the
blatant harassment
women were facing due to these streams
streamers like
xo ariel and indie fox stated that it
was
utter horseshit to think that women were
the problem
and that it was misogynistic to think so
and frankly
it's a good point because short of
breaking tos women should be able to do
whatever they want on twitch
now before amaranth got demonetized as
this issue was picking up steam online
everyone was waiting for twitch to say
something which they eventually did sort
of
dj wheat on stream who's head of
community productions for twitch
basically said hey yeah we know this is
a thing
and that was basically it we understand
at twitch that this has been getting a
lot of attention
from the community lately and we
have been watching closely our nudity
and attire policy
does allow bathing suits in an
appropriate context
and hot tubs do fall under
that criteria however what has not
changed is the sexually suggestive
and explicit content is not allowed
under the guidelines under the tos
and twitch will take action when that
is reported to us now this clip landed
like a wet fart and
people weren't impressed hoping twitch
would actually say something
meaningful but to be fair what was he
supposed to say
these hot tub streams are god's gift to
twitch so
chill out or these streams are the
devil's business and need to be stopped
twitch's whole mo is neutrality unless
forced to do otherwise so of course he
was going to take a mainline
stance and defer to the terms of service
this continued on for a while until we
eventually got to the no more ads for
amaranth situation
that i talked about earlier now when i
said that it's pretty unprecedented for
twitch to pull
ads because it is i wasn't lying
although twitch has demonetized creators
before it's typically
after they've been banned from the
platform this is the first time i can
remember
twitch demonetizing a creator but
letting them continue to stream
on twitch it's such a rare move that
according to
amaranth twitch doesn't even have a
section in its tos
or community guidelines about what
happens to a streamer
when they're quote put on this blacklist
on top of the vagueness with which
twitch
handles these situations amaranth sees
this entire
thing as an alarming precedent other
streamers not just hot tubs
i feel like it could be dangerous for
other streams that are deemed and not
advertiser friendly they would find that
most streams of big streamers aren't
advertiser friendly
that's scary for the biggest creators
because they're not like
putting on some kind of fake happy
personality just to please advertisers
like youtube kind of has to do at this
point
okay let's talk about the blog post that
announced the
hot tubs pools and beaches category
twitch starts out by explaining why
they've taken so
long to say anything about hot tubs
stating that they want to cover this
topic
respectfully and thoughtfully then they
state
quote first and foremost no one deserves
to be harassed for the content they
choose to stream
how they look or who they are and we
will take action against anyone who
perpetuates this kind of toxicity on our
service
second while we have guidelines about
sexually suggestive content
being found to be sexy by others is not
against our rules and twitch will not
take enforcement action against women
or anyone on our service for their
perceived attractiveness
end quote from there twitch points to
its tos
specifically to its nudity and attire
policy and its sexually suggestive
content policy
with this policy twitch says the
intention was to draw a line with
overtly or explicitly sexually
suggestive content
and not quote to ban content that could
be
viewed as sexually suggestive end quote
now not to nitpick or anything but in my
mind
by definition something is either
sexually suggestive
or it's not to call it overt or explicit
in this situation
is just redundant but anyway that's just
me
and then finally it addresses who i can
only imagine
is amaranth but it doesn't explicitly
state her
by name quote we recently suspended
advertising on some channels that were
flagged by the majority of our
advertiser base
and we failed to notify them our
creators rely on us
and we should have alerted affected
streamers to this change before it
happened
it was a mistake not to do so we're
working with individual creators to
address their specific situations
and restore ads where appropriate here's
amaranth on how she interpreted the blog
post when she first read it
i thought it was funny just because like
how how they had to word things
like we don't approve of sexual content
but being sexy isn't against tos and i
was just like
this is what people are mad about for
years they see a girl with cleavage like
how was this allowed
this category as i'm sure you're aware
is completely
separate from just chatting and while
amaranth says that this has been
beneficial for her
as her audience can explicitly see she's
going live in a pool
and not just in just chatting she
believes
that the discover ability is going to be
a problem in the long run
for these hot tub streamers the blog
post also states that twitch needs to do
a better job of making creators aware
of what brand safe means to advertisers
outside of the community guidelines and
this seems
in direct response to amaranth basically
saying that there was nothing to go on
no resource for creators in her position
to rely on twitch ends the blog post and
hopefully this whole controversy
by stating for the long term it's
looking to update its sexually
suggestive content policy
and as well looking at better ways to
categorize
its content so that's it for this story
is the hot tub twitch meta over
i have no idea but if it's not and we
cover this topic
again maybe it'll be from a hot tub next
time
colton put me in a [ __ ] hot tub
we're going to the beach it's the beach
episode i wonder what it would be like
to stream from an a hot tub eight out
eight hours a day
i'm a short guy as it is already i'd
turn into a raisin
i would literally just be this miniature
yoda floating around in a hot tub
wondering what my life has come to you
know what i mean
just got a giant bottle of scotch you
join the stream
[ __ ] off i'm in my hot tub there's
nothing to see here
okay i got one viewer i'm just
talking to myself floating around
life is great nobody ever sees me ever
again
you know just [ __ ]